[Music]
test good I wonder what type of people
click on a podcast episode that they see
is entitled groomer mythology yeah you
know could be people uh who are
interested in uh current events or or
people who are flirting with uh
extremist views on the internet the
groomer myth are call calling it that it
does have its downsides but I'd like to
suggest right off the bat that I've
never groomed
anybody unless you unless you mean
grooming teenagers into reading day cart
which I should not have done and I feel
very bad about but they uh they were
over 18 intro to Western
Civ yeah I guess I guess uh if you're
going to break the word grooming then
yeah but but I mean I mean grooming now
is is any if we're teaching them uh if
we're teaching them critical race Theory
we're grooming them according to
according to the uh Florida law the
don't say gay law and all the book
Banning stuff grooming actually grooming
is just uh becoming more meaningful on
its own it doesn't even need us
to use it as a metaphor anymore yeah um
it's perfect because we're doing myth
we've been doing myth in terms of
semiotics semiotic sign system myth for
weeks and when this happens to a word
that has a meaning like groom that it
now comes to mean anything including
teaching uh that's a perfect example of
myth in action and and obviously it's
it's got to be part of a narrative so
these these words kind of just get
folded into these meta narratives about
yeah I mean in this case it's uh you're
teaching kids that it's okay to be gay
are trying to make them gay yeah to the
to the the opposite argument is like
yeah that's making them gay and you're
grooming them in in such a way that to
be a part of the lgbtq community means
to abandon all Notions of childhood and
family values and phases of life and to
make them into like little sex things I
don't know it's a it's a it's a very
like extreme kind of I mean this if
you've been exposed to conspiracy theor
before you're probably used to this very
kind of extreme Distortion of of what
you know politics is about what being on
the left is about or what being social
social justice is about well if you do
see a flag I've heard this if you do see
a a rainbow flag before puberty that is
one of the main causes for gayness yeah
and this is why it's so appealing to um
I mean if if youve maybe there's you
have those I mean this is a pure ative
term but turfs right like um trans
exclusionary radical feminists who are
defending the sanctity of childhood and
family values and This this term of
grooming maybe it doesn't appeal to them
it's more of a right-wing or conspiracy
theory term but it is kind of it's it's
weird how it can pick up these meanings
it just needs to be kind of near it
needs to resonate with something and
then it gives this sort of conspiracy
theory power you know this grooming and
then you have the whole constellation of
you know the the elites and the
Hollywoods sex pedophiles and uh yes I
assume this this does have to some this
iteration of this myth does have to
somehow go back to the epan revelations
but this was the epan revelations the
second time not the first time that he
got he got charged because that didn't
really seem to matter to anyone but
despite the fact that these loud the
loudest anti-group groomers are
Christian
conservatives the international
conspiracy of the most child grooming
and the most covering up of said child
grooming certainly that award goes to
the church not to the public education
system the church is the the all-time
most successful grooming organization
award but again facts makes no
difference here uh facts do not interact
with myths myths survives uh factree
and facts can't combat it I mean that's
kind of part of the reason to take a
semiotic approach as well because you
know when you read news stories news
articles obviously written by like
Center left kind of media outlets right
they're very focused on how much these
narratives distort the facts how they're
wrong they look down on them they're not
interpreting evidence correctly or
they're just lying right but I think
when you think that way yeah it's
helpful okay to debunk mythbust whatever
these things but I think you're missing
the underlying kind of cultural and
psychological mechanisms behind
conspiratorial thinking when you just
say oh well these people are just wrong
well what about the questions of where
did this stuff come from why does it why
does it keep seeming to bring stuff back
right like qanon was not around when
Pizza gate happened right the the child
sex ring going underneath one of those
pizza parlor that Hillary Clinton was
supposedly running but that all comes
back again right once this new event
happens say I mean latest we're looking
at say Balenciaga and their uh oh yes
very
risque last year's uh thing involving
children yeah when when that happens an
event it gains significance and it gets
folded back into the into the whole
tradition of of yeah there's an
international pedophilic anic sex ring
that is either engaging in child
sacrifice or harvesting adrenochrome
from kids that remember from Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas that's a thing
they picked that up and they and they
use it as part of this whole uh I don't
know it's like I can't call it anything
other than like a Mythos or like a super
conspiracy that's what kind of qanon has
emerged as since 2017 is a super
conspiracy that folds in a lot of the
other ones and connects all these dots
in very kind of frantic and and strident
ways that is alarming and Powerful yeah
dots even from fiction um I wanted to
just quickly catch up anyone who hasn't
heard those episodes uh we've spent
about a month breaking down modern
mythologies it comes from a book from
the 50s called
mythologies by a french guy named Roland
Bart and when we say semiotics then
we're talking about sign systems so it
might be it might be a normal thought to
have maybe less normal these days but a
normal thought to have that the age of
myth has over that belongs to a
primitive belief belief system that was
crushed by the Enlightenment and the
world is
disenchanted but I would challenge you
to spend an hour on Tik Tok and be able
to argue that that's the case but it
really is interesting that these that
you can you can you can hurl facts and
appeal to facts and be like this is not
a scientific approach to the world as
much as you want um but this kind of
demonstrates why that doesn't work why
it's it's more appealing to believe in
the myths that the media runs on that
politics runs on that advertising runs
on and we've covered some of those you
know the the car
industry um and myth is not just to say
it's false it's to say that it has a
meaning structure which is what a
semiotic is so we've been looking at
that and we've done a ton of research on
this trying to find the meaning
structure of this uh groomer myth and it
comes down to a myth that we probably
all believe in actually which is uh a
good sign that it is a myth and when we
all agree on something you know
something's got to be wrong but the myth
we're looking at today is I guess we're
calling at the myth of childhood yeah I
in so far as I guess we're also talking
about cons iracy theories and
mythological Consciousness is been
identified as as a major component of
conspiratorial thinking and and I should
make the distinction between like a
conspiracy which is you know a group of
people coming up with plan usually
carried out in secret to achieve some
goal and then a conspiracy theory which
is meant to out some kind of potential
conspiracy it's a conspiracy against
conspiracy
so this so so conspiracies are real they
happen Watergate was one of them but
conspiracy theory is is kind of a
different ball game entirely because
these conspiracies they're exposing are
secret they're we're not supposed to
know or talk about them and there's no
way to prove that they've well they
usually haven't really happened yet or
they're kind of part of some grander
scheme and often you know just as
mythology is it's a battle between good
good and evil either evil people but
often you know forces of evil
Supernatural forces and and though
that's not often made explicit in
conspiracy theory chat rooms I mean you
can see it all over the place of of you
know packs with the devil and and and
satanic worship and and all of that
stuff so it's it really does have a
Hallmarks of ancient myth yeah the
Balenciaga one I especially like cuz
they brought in ball which is a
Canaanite fertility God somehow that uh
that that God had some trouble with in
the in the Old Testament in the Hebrew
Bible but ball is a part of part of this
as well um and conspiracy I I I I
haven't checked it but I guess I could
real quick but it looks etm
etymologically like conspira or
something like that would be breathing
together or Whispering together you know
our words in English respire
Inspire um that would be my that would
be my guess but it's this these people
are breathing together and then the
conspiracy theorist is telling a story
about the the breathers The Whisperers
the whispering group I love playing
those games yeah conspiracy when we all
breathe together and then we influence
each other and influences influenza
right open the window and take a deep
breath and you catch
conspiracies but today it's well the
myth let's start with the myth the myth
is childhood um and you probably believe
this one I think I do and again myth
doesn't make anything untrue it just
means it's been detached from the the
the normal world the world where it can
be corrected and and things like that so
children are a paradigm a a paradigm of
Innocence uh Purity imagination
creativity and they're like this this
white force that must be protected
against all the dark demonic influences
around it that they that seek like
actively seek to corrupt this state of
Innocence the childlike state of
Innocence um which is you know
something's true to that but I guess
it'd be just as accurate to say that
children are indelibly self-absorbed
little [__] too you know they're not
they're not necessarily truly this
Paradigm of of Purity But Eric I thought
about every every Panic about corrupting
the youth or corrupting the child really
comes down to that age-old question is
it immoral to tell a child that Santa
Claus is not
real yeah yeah yeah I mean you're you're
damaging their their minds you know it's
like it it's like they need to they need
to have this sort of uh uh they need
this this period where they can just
remain in like a cocoon of fantasy until
they're old enough to deal with the real
world and if you introduce the hard
dirty facts of reality to them to early
on it can it can uh you know it can
interrupt their proper cognitive
development maybe I don't know I'm just
I'm just spinning away I think that's
true but you can see this in even adults
you know Disney adults but how many
family movies from the '90s or like the
have this Stern businessman type father
and then the the kid believes in Santa
and the the stern father does not and
there's like a a relationship problem
between the stern father and the
imaginative child and they believe in
Santa and then it turns out that Santa
is real like or or Christmas or you know
Christmas is real elf comes to
mind uh the Santa Claus Tim Allen all
those like yeah I was going to say that
one the Miracle on on whatever
street or even uh Mel Mel Gibson's new
comeback movie where he plays the the
Santa Claus Fisher character I I never
saw it but U you know he he went through
his period of of uh of of hiding from
the public eye until everyone forgot his
his racist outburst and now he's
secretly making his way back in just as
Balenciaga is now releasing their new uh
2023 line and uh we just saw you know
that that weird mud the mud scene where
Kanye West was walking along this like
muddy track in a really really
oversized heavyduty looking set of
clothing so they're they're coming back
they've done their period of they've
done their they've done their rehab
period their silence
period yeah they've reset the clock oh I
didn't know that they're coming back
isn't he making a Jesus movie too I
would not be surprised like what do you
do Passion of the Christ three you can't
sequel that like Jesus
finished he's G I guess it could be the
The Book of Revelation he comes back
there I know you can't really write any
new material you're going to have to go
find some some alternative history for
that too yeah he'll do an extended
Universe of uh the Bible awesome
Marvel's Bible alternate universe Bible
okay let's look at these new universe
let's look at this modern myth though
the myth of childhood child has a place
of whatever Purity unrestrained
imagination and
it's sexuality is the thing that you're
not allowed to introduce into this this
universe so look true whatever really
happens the facts don't matter here it's
the
sign childhood will put the sign in a
little circle in your mind here um this
the childhood is doing the work and it's
carried away into like we've been
talking about this mythical conflict of
Good and Evil which is the basic
structure the most basic structure of
the
mythology yes um and this isn't just a
right-wing thing either because most
people probably agree with this which is
why there are institutions that decide
you know what is allowed to be on TV is
is a function of we need to protect
especially the children the arguments
for for the haze code yeah that's right
right they're introduced as we need to
protect children from these images
because the images are too powerful and
dangerous and scary and this is this is
new like you why why is it okay when
you're 13 but not when you're 12 you
know PG PG13 rating yeah it's it's hard
we're we're breaking off childhood as
like a chunk but it it always seems to
come sort of more generally with kind of
traditional family values that that
seems to be the thing that conspiracy
the are positioning themselves to
protect in a strange way right like
family values so you have this movement
that says you know you know like
heterosexuality doesn't have to be this
essentialized Norm around which we're
always constructing our whatever our
social units so the nuclear family is
maybe being questioned and then that is
great opportunity for conspiracy
theorists to start a panic about about
the traditional family Val values
specifically children and grooming and
and and child sexuality being no longer
protected right because that's that's
clearly what the LGBT community is all
about is about like pedophilia right
well well whatever whatever that's how
the that's how the qinon types are going
to argue it right and it's just folded
into this whole International conspiracy
thing but every event that occurs
whether it's a movie that comes out that
sexualizes kids right it's that
immediately reconnected to this this
overarching subversive way of yeah like
like stealing kids to get their Adrena
Chrome for Hollywood Elites or just
traffic them like that like the sound of
uh sound of Freedom movie um again
probably stuff like that happens but it
wasn't it wasn't enfolded into this
Grand story but Balenciaga I think this
is the most interesting case here
Balenciaga was really
awesome um not they are awesome I don't
I don't give a [__] but they committed
the the the Kur fuffle was awesome
because they committed a sign crime and
you don't see this happen very often
where someone just created they they did
a crime against the sign system because
materially speaking and what they did
was
um the teddy bears there was kids
holding teddy bears in these images
right the kids were holding a teddy bear
and the teddy bear had a an SNM like a
leather a leather suit on but yes here's
what I'm saying materially there's
nothing inherently sexual about a
leather suit you know it's a leather
suit yeah but in our
culture it is inscribed into the world
of sex basically as as like alternative
sexuality in a way
right exactly exactly and so the the
image is sexualized the child doesn't
know that it's sexualized because
they're not part of that that sign world
yet um but the thing that the rightwing
or I shouldn't even say the rightwing
um deviant
sexualities you know quote unquote like
homosexuality is included in the the
world of sex signs whereas a
heterosexual relationship is not yeah
you have like for for whatever reason
this is this is not like arbitrary it
goes back to like Christianity and all
this but but for whatever reason even
seeing uh a gay couple holding hands is
perceived as belonging to the sexual
sign system whereas a straight couple
holding hands is not considered sexual
it's like neutral and naturalized right
it's like a it's it's coded as normal
whereas like child sexuality or or even
children being juxtaposed like with like
the children weren't necessarily even in
any kind of SNM bondage gear but just
the the jux to position was enough to
make that connection to to to assign
this signifier a a uh a place in the in
the metatext of of uh conspiracy theory
and that was enough it didn't it didn't
matter you know Balenciaga tried to sue
the people who like the company they
hired out to to make that scene they
tried to sue them and then they
apologized for that later they they
admitted to doing a sign crime by trying
to sue the the creator of that and they
they ascribed it to oh yeah we just
didn't like check it closely enough and
and there is also this document very
deviously placed that was about some um
some Supreme Court decision about child
pornography
and and and it it's all very strange it
seems like they were trying to do
something kind of edgy and and it just
it it just but yeah they went too far
but the point is it got picked up by
conspiracy theorists and folded back
into this grooming homophobia satanic
Panic stuff right yeah wrong place wrong
time but you know if you want children
to not be exposed to sexual imagery I
mean how here's a personal question how
did you first see porn I think I was
probably nine and one of my friends St
like a magazine from their dad or
something like that remember the good
old days those the mag the magazines oh
yeah I didn't I didn't have any older
siblings the ma the magazines were I saw
my friends with those things but it was
probably more so the uh the the
peer-to-peer software once that started
coming out obviously the very first
thing it was filled with yeah kazah lime
wire Aries Napster all those old school
ones
that yeah the obviously the first thing
that they were filled up with was porn
and parents don't understand that [__]
so they can't put parental controls on
it and I still imagine that's the that's
a big anxiety around having you need to
create like a controlled uh uh digit
virtual atmosphere for your children
where they won't accidentally click on
anything that'll take them somewhere and
show them things you don't want them to
see I I I assume that's how kids are
Expos so it's it's tablets and phones
that are that are doing the grooming
that are invading this uh the Mythic
purity of children I would expect far
more than something like the school
system because when do you get sexed in
school like I think I was grade six for
for me or grade five yeah I don't know
if the the the history of it is
interesting right because we were
looking at this very famous book that
was written called centuries of
childhood oh yeah Philip Aras
and this is one of the first major
points where there it was argued that
childhood is a modern concept it's a
modern phenomenon and by modern we mean
like kind of going into the 16th 15th
century like post Renaissance or kind of
modern so before that Purity couldn't
have even been a kind of issue with
specifically with childhood right Purity
has been an issue and you know it has
very religious overtones but but once
children became a kind of a a
conceptualized and distinct phase of
human life with its own rules and its
own you know protocols that have to be
followed in order to raise a child
properly suddenly like the purity of
children became a very specific
focus and uh it's it's interesting so
that's where that's perhaps where some
of this the impetus to protect
save the children comes from and and
also Fuko talks a lot about this too in
in the the figure of the the child
masturbator is is a new figure in the
19th century so all these ideas anyway
are coming up about childhood over the
modern period and how children should be
and that's where that that that's got to
be some of the historical basis for this
although some of these plot types are
much older yeah the guy who started you
know Kellogg serial that guy who I don't
remember his first name but the K
Kellogg guy was in addition to making
Corn Flakes obsessed with child
masturbation and there's like a book of
signs that you can tell if your kid's
masturbating or not because it's going
to cause like acne and stuff like this
so it's a weird thing for a grown ass
adult businessman to be obsessed with
but but there you go and look yeah not
not so different from like a a manual
for how to find out witches right how to
discover the signs that there are
witches around right what to look for in
people right and so you can take that
and be like okay what to look for for
the child masturbator and I think what
Fuko is talking about is also like um
children that will run around and like
masturbate other people like doing like
kind of forms of prostitution and stuff
like that right like that became a major
concern in the 19th century and it was
Psychiatry that that kind of staked its
fortune on on
normalizing the family around the mother
father parent child situation the
nuclear
family yeah yeah so that's coming up in
the 18th 19th century the the Psychiatry
movement which as we know in the 20th
century gave way to the anti- Psychiatry
movement not not till much later but
psychiatry originally had a stake in in
how children were and and I guess you
could say maybe imposing Bourgeois
values and and fears and anxieties onto
the general
population and this is one of the most
important parts of what makes a myth a
myth that you you mentioned the book uh
centuries of childhood but the book
basically argues that before the 17th
century I believe there's no concept or
category really of of childhood
childhood is not its own thing that's
distinct from adulthood because of
conditions and all this stuff you like
we have at least three categories which
is child then teenager the teenager is a
more recent invention um which was I
think like the 40s even but you have
child now teenager now adult but before
that there just was no concept of
childhood this guy aru so its
introduction into the science system was
contingent it's not a natural category
we think of it as as a natural category
because of like you said psychology and
Psychiatry that there's differences
there but I want to stress this it's not
always been the case and that's kind of
how a myth emerges and how it builds
itself now now we can recognize it our
own experience we can recognize it
naturally as just a uh a consumer
demographic like I assume a 100 years
ago there were no children's books
specifically for children or maybe maybe
longer than that 150 and children's toys
that are distinct from adult
toys um but CH now children's toys
backpacks diapers they're clearly marked
they're clearly laid in they usually
have like Disney characters and Mickey
Mouse and cars all over them and there's
a bunch of I was there's a bunch of
these two kids channels in YouTube
speaking of speaking of grooming um but
in the top five channels of YouTube like
they're at least two of them are just
specifically selling [__] to children so
I find I found it interesting that this
anything any exposure of a sexual image
to a child is considered corrupting
their purity
but exposing them to the
market uh a predatory you could call it
Market of of advertising which is
demonstrably psychologically damaging
but this is not considered uh
grooming yeah which is completely in
line again with this conspiracy theory
Universe where they position themselves
as Defenders of competitive markets
right against socialism so you have that
sort of Hangover of the McCarthy era
right where Communists are infiltrating
the government at all levels and
conspiring to bring about a new world
order based on socialist principles
right so at least in the west you
actually have a probably have a parallel
Theory like that but towards capitalism
in C in certain other places but in in
North America the dominant strain is is
fear over you know socialist values
creeping in and and getting rid of
markets right so clearly yeah
introducing children to the market as
early as possible doesn't become a
doesn't become a controversial thing as
long as you have you know regulatory
bodies that that look at the content of
the films you're showing them and make
sure that you're not
advertising cigarettes to kids although
you can kind of find workarounds with
candy cigarettes and things and Big
League Chew for uh Che teaching kids to
love sticking tobacco in the front of
their lip and stuff like
that but you know those things are very
kind of subtle and and they're kind of
clever right they don't get they don't
get the attention that something like
you know yeah a cartoon character who's
signified as gay would get then then
suddenly you're in full-blown moral
panic mode because you've presented them
with a gay character and and you're
sending certain messages through that
according to the according to the
paranoid response yeah it's associating
with the the word the uh sexual imagery
for for reasons that can be traced uh
homosexuality is included like I said in
the sexual universe and straight people
are not but um if we look back to this
creation of the childhood we can't
really separate it this is what myth
does it
naturalizes uh history
away and doesn't doesn't want it to it
can't look at its own contingency really
we think think of childhood as a natural
state a natural state of innocence and
there's some like philosophy that dealt
with this a little bit like uh rouso
wrote a book on how to educate a child
he wasn't very good at at children
though he just left uh left orphans all
over Europe and abandoned his own
children but he told everyone else how
how childhood education should go but if
you think about this he didn't practice
what he preached yeah but if you think
about this from a like a class
perspective as we talked with with uh
Diego uh two episodes ago you wouldn't
have needed a category of childhood
until something like uh public school
which was sort of a Bourgeois invention
because before that I would assume
something like when the kid is ready to
start working they can uh they can go to
work and now you're suddenly in adult
cleaning up cleaning the Looms with your
tiny fingers in uh the English factories
yeah yeah it's it's easy to forget that
the public schooling system grew up in
proximity to yeah industrialization and
and struggles over the Working Day and
labor laws and and and women and
children in the work place and yeah
public the public schooling system as a
kind of
democratization of
education uh I mean it seems like a
noble and and institution today and of
course it is but I mean yeah it comes
from educating people to be part of a
Workforce not to be you know
self-realization self-realizing
individuals with aspirations that's
that's foolish right look at how public
schools are set up right batches but
based on years and certain kinds of uh
things they have to know by the the time
they're out so that they can go into the
workplace or go on to higher education
but it kind of also produces the
interregnum period where now a child can
be created you know the concept of child
not an actual child but the concept of
child is not yet working so we gave them
something to do during the day Reading
Writing rhythmetic
yeah yeah it's like there it's like a
it's like a little period of of um just
free freedom and protection from the
world just to grow and develop on their
own it's no longer you know kids are the
ones who are going to take over the
family business so you just get them
they're probably living in the workplace
they're living in the workshop they're
receiving the same sort of Education
their parents would have received which
is just whatever the parents are passing
on to them and showing them how to do
they're not getting a formal education
but that all changes in the modern era
you have public schools and
industrialization yeah I was I even
brought up uh William Blake had a lot to
say in poetry especially about children
in newly
industrialized Britain and and some of
those jobs that they were given because
they were small adults they're being
treated as small adults so they're sent
into the chimneys to be chimney sweeps
because they're the only ones who can
fit cleaning out those coal burning
chimneys or even in coal mining right
kids could go through little holes and
drag stuff around much better than
larger adults and and and he was pretty
outraged and there there's a lot of
people including you know
people in the
aristocratic Echelon too who who were
who are very upset at this kind of
treatment of children but even you even
find it all over like Marx as well you
know kids being put in to work in
factories and in appalling conditions
and paid half the amount an adult would
be paid and that sort of thing yeah so
that's that's another dimension of it
the labor the child's literally half an
an adult but they can fit under you know
the Looms it can fit under the machines
in a way that an an adult can't yeah and
he mentioned that these kids would be
put together in workplaces not divided
by gender so the kids would be all put
together there might even be older
people there with them and he and he
kind of speculates about what kind of
depravity is is going on in these places
which are basically kind of boarding
houses for the workers of a factory and
if the factory employs children they're
often just thrown in there amongst the
adults and not really supervised
properly and and they become you know
kind of rough because of that because
they're treated so poorly yeah this is
the beginning of Oliver Twist right he's
in a he's in a workhouse when he asks
for more food and then he's cast
out yeah Dickens Dickens wrote some
pretty powerful stuff stuff pointing
that that kind of thing out too yeah but
this is I guess well the reason we're
bringing this up is these are the first
instances
of uh responding to like direct
conditions responding to conditions in
front of your face and then pointing it
out and saying you know this is wrong to
do this to these people you can do it to
adults but it's a Bourgeois creation of
the public school system after this as a
result of you know liberals basically
saying we should take them out they
should be educated they should have
access to some kind of life of the mind
this is what it was on its face anyway
and it should be public and it it began
you know private expensive and sort of
became quote unquote universalized as a
as a liberal value there um which is to
protect children from the market or that
the labor market the workplace is this
first instance of honing off or defining
as separate childhood as something that
needs to be
defended yeah and like kind of
implicitly accepting aras's argument
that childhood is a modern concept and
so outlining some of this stuff but it
makes sense to me when we think back
even to our episode on on fairy tales
right because they're they are tales
about children but the children are kind
of ambiguous they seem very adults like
we did we kind of looked at at Little
Red Riding Hood on the side we didn't
say much about it but Little Red Riding
Hood is given this very adult task of
going through the woods right or but
which one did we actually read like Snow
White right or no Sleeping Beauty that's
the one we did right and uh no Snow
White I was right Snow White and again
ambiguous kind of what phase of life is
she in we kind of have an idea of what
age she might be but she's simply just
presented is a fully formed human being
so it seems it seems like even fairy
tales kind of confirm a little bit that
these really old stories they don't make
this modern distinction between
childhood and adulthood and that the
traditional way of doing it versus the
modern way of making that
distinction now ironically is reversed
the traditional ways to make that
distinction and now the modern way is
bluring those lines again the the The
Conspiracy Theory does have a way of
kind of turning things upside down like
that and in the childhood or in the in
the fairy stories there's definitely not
I mean as opposed to the Disney
infantilized version of the fairy
stories there's definitely no like moral
line there because at the end you know
the evil stepsister the evil stepsisters
have to dance on a fire until they die
and and burn to death and this is seen
as as retributive Justice
for their treatment of Cinderella yeah
the witch the W the witch has to wear
the the the hot the hot sandals and
dance to death yeah yeah and these are
these are tales about children they
might have been told in the presence of
children but you can really see the
switch between the Original Stories and
then the dnic of those stories which is
the Purity thing we've been talking
about right nobody can die in those
stories everybody has to be you know
nice and beautiful and and often very
white whitewashed in the earlier ones
right Disney disn
ification I think that means to
everybody that it's going to be very
watered down nothing really high stakes
is going to happen except something
scary but it's going to all be fun and
and playful in the end nobody's going to
die in the end horrifically like they
often do in the old stories right and in
addition to their like this sign system
system we can see over basically 150
plus years is built to
include now the child in the form that
we receive it today and the form that we
receive it today is what we say we call
naturalized myth where we we look around
the world and say of course it's like
that this isn't a contingent production
this isn't invented because of all this
history that we're going through which
is the reason that we're going through
it and similarly at basically the same
time well a little later I would say
like uh 20th century also develops this
rigorous sign system about
sexuality like I don't think at any time
in history it was uh considered Haram
for children to see breasts for
example but with the haze code as one
example of of a of a of a larger code a
cultural code now breasts become
something sexual and they must be
covered up as opposed to I don't know
the the male nipple yeah and I I really
wish I read on more more on Freud
specifically for this topic but yeah
like those those erogenous zones and and
really like the psychosexual development
of children even talking about that
stuff can make people kind of
uncomfortable it still does when you
bring up an edus complex and then
explain to somebody what it is they go
and it's gross right but Freud's saying
you know our literary our earliest
literary Masters like Sophocles actually
had a kind of pre psychoanalytic theory
going or not a unified theory but they
were the forerunners of of his own
insights right he takes them up yeah I
wish I read more of that for today but
that's the way it goes with such a
enormous topic as as this
and I would even bring in one more sort
of overarching component of conspiracy
theory as it at least relates directly
to Childhood is is Catholicism and the
Catholic church we already mentioned
it but some of the earliest conspiracy
theories were focused one on Masons
Freemasonry so some of the earliest
conspiracies were anti-masonic
claiming that you know and there are
famous people involved in these debates
like the guy who invented Morse code he
was writing screeds against the Mason
Guild like surprising
himself yeah like they are yeah he says
here the quote the uh celebrated painter
and inventor of the telegraph sfb moris
says quote within my quote a conspiracy
exists it's plans are already in
operation we are attacked in a
vulnerable quarter which cannot be
defended by our ships our forts our
armies and this is what the author then
says about that the main source of the
conspiracy Morse found in metnick
government this is a Prussian military
leader uh saying Austria is now acting
in this country which is America in this
country she Austria has devised the
grand scheme she has organized a plan
for doing something here she has her
Jesuit missionaries traveling through
the land she has supplied them with
money and has furnished a fountain for a
regular Supply why
Austria cuz apparently Austria is um
like the HS the
H yeah yeah the habsburgs right they
apparently they're involved in some kind
of um Pro Catholic
oh right they're involved in a kind of
pro Catholic conspiracy so the
anti-catholic that's what I wanted to
say I I presented this in the worst way
possible the earliest ones are
anti-masonic and then the other one is
anti-catholic those are the two kind of
Proto conspiracy theories right so Morse
is writing here about the Jesuits being
the Agents of a Catholic conspiracy to
undermine Protestant individualist
culture and freedom and markets and
things like that impos a new order
another right the the pope like another
quot the pope is the Antichrist
there yeah yeah kind of papal plot and
so another Protestant militant writes
here and I quote again in this article
the the paranoid style that Jesuits are
prowling about all parts of the United
States in every possible disguise
expressly to ascertain the advantageous
situations and modes to disseminate poer
po not poer but the pope stuff popery a
a minister of the Gospel from Ohio has
informed us that he discovered one
carrying on his devices in his
congregation he says that the Western
Country swarms with them under the name
of puppet showmen dancing Masters music
teachers pedlers of imagery and
ornaments Barrel organ players and so
this anyway they had this paranoid kind
of leap into the fantasy of of some kind
of global plot to undermine in this case
protestantism right so you have you know
the
Masonic reaction to the Masonic
anti-masonic reaction which are
generally a reaction to the uh to the
French Revolution and then the anxieties
that that provoked in other countries
and then you have this now sort of
protestant Catholic kind of back and
forth being folded into its own kind of
conspiracy right with the Jesuits and
the pope plotting to undermine free
society and and all the good values that
come along with the Protestants right so
you know that that that Catholic basis
then be quickly you know you can imagine
how that picks up meaning over time you
know Catholic abuse of children this and
that all these isolated things just get
folded back into to this sort of
anti-catholic version of conspiracy
theory and we're skipping a few but I I
mean this is so it's so particularly
American to be like the Pope's trying to
take over your country um but also we've
skipped a few like baet is a uh
bastardization of
Mohammad so there's this the the Muslims
are trying to take [__] over and of
course
the the Jews we can't ignore the Jews
the we have the Illuminati which are the
the Masons on one hand and then the the
Jewish conspiracy which riled everybody
up not just in America but Europe as
well yeah yeah some know it all has
probably told you at some point that the
Illuminati aren't a real thing they are
based on the Bavarian Illuminati of the
of of History gone by and they're no
longer around right well that yeah I
mean that that is kind of the the start
of this conspiracy is is this Bavarian
Illuminati and this movement
to I don't know it's a it's a illuminism
it's called in this article and it was
started in 1776 by a man named Adam Vice
hopt who worked at the University of
inat and somehow the Knights Templar
started in like the 11th century that
gets all mixed up in this but these are
like oh yeah Assassin's Creed amazing
game good stuff on that this goes back
to the like any these secret societies
there SE to be threats to the good the
public good at large and we've just
named a bunch of them uh we don't have
to go into detail into any of them but
the point is that in the modern myth
in the groomer myth all of these things
become interchangeable in the war of
good versus evil so sexuality is on the
side of evil uh whatever whatever group
is the the target of the day that's
threatening the public social order they
become part of the evil and childhood
it's like we we don't want to just
defend ourselves from these people
because you know we're adults we can
take it but children they need to be
defended so everything we do is on
behalf of them everything we WE Post and
cons and and uh you know fighting the
good fight we're not doing it for
ourselves because we're so benevolent
and good we must though protect the
children we must protect the children
from Satan and whatever the Satan figure
is it was literally Satan in in the
80s and now it's um groomer groomer
pedophiles and gays ah yeah but Satan
will be there right in the stable of ref
is ready to trot out if if one of these
incidents seems to have a particularly
kind of religious if you can find a
religious signifier there right then the
Satan part of that myth will be readily
deployed but it doesn't have to be right
it's it's a on the here's an interesting
quote right so there's a there's a uh an
Estonian semiotician very famous named
Yuri lotman and I'm reading a paper that
is you know discussing his his views in
relation to this subject it says the
value of a sign in the semantic
hierarchy is determined by its proximity
to the originary order provided by the
metatext okay so the metatext is you
know the the conspiracy theory in its
sort of General amorphous form uh and an
event or a sign a sign can be an event
is put into that IC hierarchy based on
how well it fits in right so again to
continue the quote while the originary
order is included in every event
perceived as significant in some it is
nevertheless thought to be more clearly
present right so the event kind of has
it's the opposite right we don't do the
Empirical research and then try to come
up with a theory to explain the
questions we look for the events that
already fit best with our Theory it's
that classic thing right
but in this case it is the mythological
Consciousness that determines what the
originary order is the cosmic Battle of
Good and Evil right which is why there's
always that weird kind of Satan stuff
ready to come out when when any kind of
incident like Balenciaga happens right
the they're going to trot it all out
interestingly though with the Balenciaga
thing they went back to Bal which again
or Bale ba bael which is a Canaanite
rain God for whatever reason he's being
roped into this the guy that you pray to
so that you're your grains get get
watered I'm really I'm really interested
in what you said there though because we
call it you know when we're saying
you're not doing facts you're
cherry-picking the evidence basically
what you're saying is these events are
cherry-picked based on their sign value
Do you have a you're you're an expert in
semiotics where does this sign value
come from is it just their flexibility
or is it the the emotional resonance
obviously when you're talking about
child grooming it's emotionally resonant
to everyone like I don't want my kids to
be exposed to this when they're out of
my care for eight hours a day what what
where does the sign value come from yeah
the the sign value I mean this is in a
kind of register closer to Ferdinand to
so's idea of the value of a sign being
its difference from the other signs in a
formal Semitic system so when we're
dealing with a system like language
right the value of a sign is
differential right and the example
always given is stop lights right when
we pull up and see a green light well
it's not red it's not yellow that's what
gives it its value in that system if you
have a metatech
like like a like a like a a conspiracy
theory related to Children right if the
event or the image being presented on
social media or the event has religious
signifiers in it like baale right that's
really close to the originary text right
that's got huge value that's much more
densely connected then something that
might be a little harder to connect like
uh I don't know if
like just a horrific incident where
children are dying but there's no
there's no signifiers available there to
make it seem like it's part of some
Global conspiracy or cabal so the value
is is determined by the metatext of the
conspiracy and the conspir The
Conspiracy Theory I should say and the
conspiracy theory itself is a I mean the
terminology here is a transcultural
metatext so think of it just like you
know the Fall of Troy was the
transcultural metatext for hundreds and
hundreds of years right you have hesiod
Homer like all the Athenian playwrights
right it's a transcultural metatext
they're talking about this sort of
Mythos this universe of the fall of Troy
and the time before when gods and humans
walked the earth and the time after the
Fallen time afterwards right that's
another example of what a metatext would
be so you find a stone tablet that says
something about Zeus hey that's close to
the originary order in the theogony boom
that has high value whereas you know one
of the grandchildren of thesis gets
himself killed fighting a monster or
something right still there but less
value right it's more distantly
connected to the originary kind of
cosmic order of things and and the
struggles of the unfolding of that
Cosmic order and battle against good and
evil and all that good stuff I think did
I explain that okay I think that's all
right I think just to clarify though um
so the the transcultural metatext is I
guess Christian mythology is what you're
saying here so this is why Satan and B
are
reintroduced to in Tik Tok in Tik Tok um
yeah the the actual quote for that part
is you know mythological Consciousness
is characterized by its focus on the
sacral order contained in a trans
cultural metatext so the sacral order is
contained in the transcultural metatext
events in the here and now
images statements made in public
whatever they get linked to that
transcultural metatext and their value
is then determined by how high on that
semantic hierarchy of the conspiracy
that that signifier is able to be
connected I can't it's difficult right
so pizzagate you know you have to
connect that to Hillary Clinton and then
to the international cabal of satanic
child molesters so it's got It's got
pretty high value right same with the
Balenciaga thing you see the kids okay
just like weird and Avant guard oh SNM
gear and a Supreme Court decision
against child pornography okay yeah this
is part of the elite conspiracy to
snatch up our kids and harvest adenoc
Chrome from them or something like that
right like that's basically the kind of
semantic logic is how closely to that
originary order that the signifier can
obviously be made to be
connected so if I can if I can ask you
how like where does it fit into the
order um
Christianity piggybacked off of a
certain sect of Judaism phasical Jud
Judaism which par or which uh
piggybacked off
Zoroastrianism and Zoro ism is this
manikian conflict where you have a hurda
the pure good and then the pure evil so
in in the Christian
Mythos actually Satan is supposed to not
have power so we're actually
reintroducing an older manikian Universe
here where it's a kind of an equal
struggle between good and evil rather
than we have this all powerful God so is
that is that kind of what you're saying
is it the semantic value of good versus
evil as equivalent forces and we need to
be soldiers of light uh with our swords
defending the children from any demonic
images that they might see is this more
compelling is this is this showing that
this is a little bit of a more
compelling story
than Jesus came and saved everyone
already so we don't have to worry about
it too
much oh yeah yeah because in the end
these conspiracy theory narratives are
being strategically deployed in order to
achieve certain goals but there's also
you know that's the most worrying part
about conspiracy theory is is groups
consciously using them to you know so
descent cause chaos and and further
their agendas and then there's the not
harmless but less uh focused kind of
just entertainment conspiracy and
there's no real clear boundary between
the to right the the stronger that sort
of aimless stuff can be the more uh the
more dangerous and and readily people
might jump onto or be manipulated by
people who are coming in and consciously
using it you could think of like an
Edward Bernay type getting his hands on
something like that right I was just
going to bring this up because there's a
CIA document about
fermenting uh unrest that Bernay
certainly had input into and the CIA
Playbook I made a video on this a while
back but the CIA Playbook is about
drawing phenomena together and they
include stuff like weather if you have
freakish weather you can bring that
together with the uh what do you call it
the the narrative The metatextual
Narrative um and I wanted to say this
connects materially I would think and
I'm this is I'm not really a conspiracy
theorist in the sense that I think this
is very well organized but you do have
particularly in the United States a push
by Christian conservative groups very
wealthy ones uh including what was her
name Betsy
DeVos right they want to defund or they
want Public Funding to go to their
private religious schools because
they're kind of christologically minded
we need to keep our kids pure and have
them sent to sent to a Christian school
or The Homeschool movement equivalent
the the public school system is bad and
indoctrinating your kids into feminism
and secularism and whatever else that is
is cast as demonic here so if you could
say there's a material interest at base
here and again I'm not suggesting that
this is being thought through but if it
were being thought through if it were
actually a conspiracy that was
orchestrated like this the purpose might
be something like to se
distrust and discontent in the public
school system so we can realize our uh
Christo fascist takeover of the
Republic
yeah and when you're talking about that
manikian stuff too yeah you know you can
even think of well there's this really
interesting concept called structural
maximalism which is basically just to
say that conspir iry theories are all or
nothing either you're thinking non-c
conspiratorially in which life is messy
and there are no true oppositions
between things uh or you're thinking
mythologically in in a kind of paranoid
register where everything is sort of
against something else or everything is
connected right you you immediately
parse things out into good and evil
friend and foe ordering chaos all those
binary opposites binary structural
maximalism right so even just think of
the Star Wars Universe right what does
red mean in your daily life when you
encounter it okay now when you know
you're watching a Star Wars movie what
does red signify Evil dark Side Cosmic
force of of stealing kids from the Jedi
Temple and and brainwashing them and
turning them into evil wizards evil
space Wizards right that's again a great
example of more a more contained
structural maximalism but imagine yeah
conspiracy theory kind of just floating
trans trans culturally and trans
historically through social media and
all of our interactions with people and
our meaning making activities right if
you get into a kind of a structural
maximalism when you're dealing with
those situations then yeah you're going
to interpret things in this very
polarizing kind of again like
metatextual framework and it's partly a
cultural and a partly a psychological
kind of Mech but these are these are
semiotic theories so it's the kind of
the logic of the sign ification of of of
mythical thinking in conspiratorial
thinking and it's I would just say it's
kind of obvious right if there's very
clear binaries very clear oppositions
this is much more likely to get you
involved you know who the friend is you
know who the foe is and it's much more
enticing to jump on on on one side or
the other as opposed to a world that's
presented a little bit more messily I
would say say and I I wonder what you
thought about this cuz you've you've
been referencing the Greek Mythos a lot
and the Greek Mythos doesn't have
concepts of good versus evil so how does
their myth play out differently on a
cultural level when it's not based on a
fundamentally binary system of something
like good and
evil well it's difficult to say because
you know structuralism has had a lot of
success in studying ancient myth right
uh Jean Pierre Vernon is that his name
vernant who is a favorite reference of a
famous philosopher who died a couple
years ago Bernard
stegler uh but Vernon writes a lot about
binary oppositions in Greek thought as
evidenced through mythological texts
yeah so in in Greek mythology yeah
you're right there tends not to be those
maybe Global or Universal binaries like
good and evil um but there is the Chaos
and Order thing there right in the
beginning was chaos the kaym the Gap and
out of it emerged all the gods and
eventually when you get by the time you
get to the end of the theogony you have
a a an order established under the
patriarchal rule of Zeus who is above
everybody else and it's about the
settlement of the universe into a cosmic
order so we go the opposite way now we
the order is already being there and
Chaos threatening at every turn right so
it's it's kind of it they're there
they're there they're just not you know
you need hundreds of years you need
Christianity you need miikanism you need
all these like absolutizing theories of
Good and Evil theory of God things like
that before you maybe get to what you're
asking about but yeah in Greek think
thought there's plenty of those kinds of
binary oppositions they're just a little
more local like seeing and being
invisible or something like that right
just little simpler oppositions that
structure the stories that you're
reading and perhaps civilization and
barbarism yeah exactly the Greeks are
very elitist in that sense yeah self and
other um you know myth is very much an
aristocratic phenomenon so you know
ingroup warrior class outgroup non-w
warrior class slave class what ever they
are the so yeah I mean it does have this
sort of same effect you could say yeah
there's a structural maximalism there
too and you know and these stories are
are cultural touchstones for
understanding the world uh and when we
say today you know in times of social
Stress and Anxiety and uncertainty this
kind of ancient form of mythological
thinking this mythological Consciousness
tends to reemerge in times of stress and
times of uncertainty and and what times
are not stressful and uncertain these
days yeah like they they always are with
climate change and moral panic and and
and polarizing politics right we're all
stressed out we're all looking for ways
to understand the world these things
simplify all that complexity give you a
nice vocabulary to talk about it and
everything tends to make sense of course
I'm just saying this is the appeal of it
right this is this is why it catches on
so when there's a social stress or
social
uncertainty the the most stable system
the most stable belief system what
you're calling structural maximalism is
to turn everything into a
binary and left versus right liberal
versus conservative pedophiles versus
non-
pedophiles Christians good Christian
soldiers versus Satan yeah or even you
know Protestants versus like evil
plotting Catholics or you know the the
evil Masons and all that stuff right
like here's the definition um when we
think of the meaning side again semantic
thinking it's characterized by quote
structural maximalism in which every
conflict that casts even the slightest
suspicion on the originary order takes
on the image of the battle between good
and evil so the originary order say
something important in that system is is
family values and then you see kids next
to bears with bondism gear that
challenges the originary order and it
immediately takes on the image of a
battle between good and evil there's no
inter continuing the quote here no
intermediary forms are recognized the
world is binary Order of Chaos good evil
friend foe etc etc and end quote and
those C were my Edition but yeah and
there is there is a binary there too
with the child versus the adult it's
like the adult has already been lost to
culture they've been exposed to the evil
but the children has not yet so as an
adult even though you are
corrupted even though you are you're
burdened with the original sin of having
uh scen pornography you can still take
the side of the good the not yet corrupt
and be on their side against the forces
of
evil yeah like it's a Pure Fantasy like
this fight engaged in against the forces
of evil is obviously a kind of fantasy
projection I mean often times right
conspiracy theorists are using these
topics to explore the things about
themselves that they can't talk about so
they project them onto other people oh
these people are like pedophiles doing
these things to kids I'm not saying
conspiracy theorists are all pedophiles
what I am saying is it is it is a way of
of of filtering those feelings
through a kind of discourse
right tend to would you say like
psychologically they sense their own
corruption or their own I don't
know passivity or inability to change
things because in the system a child is
an object right the child has no Agency
for itself there's no conception of the
kid wanting to see porn and then
stealing their parents' phone and like
Googling porn this doesn't exist the
child is a is a blank slate of innocence
and maybe maybe you could say that the
conspiracy theorist about this feels
somewhat of a burden of their own
corruption their own loss of innocence
and their own inability to do anything
about it so it's projected as well at
least I can defend it I can
defend children from being exposed to
you know the darkness that I've
seen yeah yeah well
yeah and and it's important to it's not
because of maybe a feeling of of any
kind of internal corruption or a sense
of that it's it's it's a a fact of
dispossession I think again you know you
have people who are dispossessed right
they don't feel like politics is going
in their direction right or you feel
like you know yeah I mean we all had
those conversations about why people
voted for Trump right the feeling of
feelings of dispossession
they were left behind they fell through
the corx of the welfare state whatever
and they turned to more extreme views I
mean you got to think that that is in
the background too it's not you don't
want to attribute this to to individuals
it's it's a cultural phenomenon like I
said when you you know when you're in
your life and you're in a relatively
good mood you have a pretty high
tolerance for uncertainty and lack of
structure and and maybe even if you wax
a bit poetic you can enjoy the
uncertainty and the contingent y but
when you're having trouble dealing with
life as as many of us often do then that
becomes a huge burden right the
uncertainty of it all and you can
imagine that on almost like a social
psychological level where widespread
uncertainty and dispossession can lead
to large groups of people embracing
these kinds of quote unquote explanatory
theories of why [__] sucks right yeah
and I'd like to I'd like to reference
back to our
we we did an episode last episode was on
myth or two episodes ago excuse me was
on myths of the left and myths of the
right because
leftism Orthodox Marxism has its own
binary right
proletariat
Bourgeois um and I've seen or we've
we've all seen so many of these um
basically online strategy debates about
why why can't we get people to believe
in our binary because this is the one
that's materially testable but I think
obviously precisely because it's not
materially testable it doesn't have Gods
it doesn't H can't include bael into it
you can see why the the one is far more
seductive than the other because it
seems much easier to to combat
pedophiles than it does to combat a
ruling class CL or an ownership class
plus every incentive that exists in the
system is trying to push you the other
way which is why leftists only have bad
myths according to uh Roland Bart yeah
and maybe it it's also helpful to
believe that that all these events are
connected so anywhere I choose to
intervene is having an effect on the
whole right right the hole is visible in
the part and then the part is is is
visible in a in a hole hole a w o l e
hole and when you so but then you know
Hollywood child abuse pizzagate
Balenciaga those are not connected well
sorry I'm making factual statements now
if you see those things as connected
then it makes it much clearer what's
going on if they're just just instances
of people being [__] up power hungry
greedy Disturbed but they're isolated
and contingent and they just happen then
how do you process that right like oh
God we' just live in this horrific world
where people are capable of of somehow
making being okay with you know sex
trafficking underage people right it's
it's much more easy to accept that
reality if you have this sort of big
story I think and I think conspiracy
theory gives you that and it makes you
the shitty of your own situation you can
then have someone to blame for it you
have somebody who's made you this way or
or somebody who's plotting to overthrow
the stability that you've been enjoying
for many years or right whatever
whatever it might be and you have a role
to play Onward Christian Soldiers yeah
yeah and then yeah you get to be a
soldier in the Army right yeah and watch
your your hero Trump or whatever fight
the satanic
pedophiles yeah even though he hasn't
really done much and yeah I mean the
real world problems with that sort of
thing as well you know it does take a if
if you're coming up with all these crazy
explanations about why child abuse
happens then you're going to be ignoring
like the real world causes and you're
going to be screwing over you know
Doctors Without Borders or which is
probably a George Soros thing or
something right but anyway you're going
to be interfering with people like
Doctors Without Borders of ability ility
to put out rhetoric and intervene in
such situations because this crazy
theory is going around
right yeah well takes
away we just covered a shitload but
anyway the the constellation here
between
Satan uh Satan against children it's not
new it's in fact one of the oldest myths
we have but nevertheless mythal and
actually the the last thing I'll say
that reminds me the last thing I'll say
about this is actually yeah the the myth
of childhood and anti-
Catholic conspiracy theories and this
panic over you know child abuse they
actually all have a very common origin
I'll just read it because it's a it's a
fascinating passage um he says probably
the most um the most widely read
contemporary book in the United States
before Uncle Tom's Cabin was a work
supposedly written by one Maria monk
entitled awful disclosures this appears
in
1836 uh this Maria monk the author who
purported to have escaped from hotel de
nunnery in Montreal after 5 years there
as a novice and nun reported her Convent
life in elaborate and circumstantial
detail reported having been told by the
mother's Superior she must obey the
priest in all things and to her utter
astonishment and horror she soon found
what the nature of such a obedience was
infants born of convent liaison were
baptized and then killed she said so
that they might Ascend at once to Heaven
her book hotly attacked and defended
continued to be read and believed even
after her mother gave testimony that
Maria had been somewhat addled ever
since childhood after she rammed a
pencil into her head Maria died prison
in 1849 after having been arrested in a
brothel as a pickpocket so the uh the
sexually nefarious goings on and
cloistered communities is uh one of the
originary parts of what we're talking
about today and of course it goes back a
little to the anti-catholicism kind
of yeah yeah it's that I mentioned
earlier anti- Catholicism and child
sacrifice yeah yeah
a child sacrifice as well it has a molok
I think the the God was but I I think
the Hebrew Bible alleges that molok or
people were sacrificing their children
to molok so there we go uh the papacy
demands child sacrifice and here is
molok and everything you believe can be
traced to the common source of a lady
who stuck a pencil in her head yeah and
the and the and the Jesuit infiltrators
that the habsburgs are sending over here
in funding well we should say like you
can find facts you can find in
individual events but the point of the
myth and we're not discounting that of
course but the point of the myth is to
unify all of the
independent uh contingent variables that
are dependent on whatever their own
circumstances are including some [__]
up people but the myth draws them all
together makes one grand story that's
been uh taking place for at least what
3,000
years yep the evidence is wide open to
interpretation you can say whatever you
want about it you go on go onto some
chat room and look at whatever they're
interpreting and they'll be
contradicting each other one of those
interpretations will eventually win out
and that's like the petri dish effect
right on the internet in the eight Chans
and the four Chans of the world right
it's a little petri dish these things
grow one of them becomes dominant then
foom they're sent out into the cyers
sphere and they take over our minds and
our behaviors which I'll say is
fascinating I I like it when it
happens I know and it's happening so
much now internet yada yada yada post
Cold War there's so many components to
these stories it's it's and the history
of where all this stuff came from I
should say yeah it's it's a it's
overwhelming but fascinating yeah anyway
I thought that was a great episode we
can wrap it there though uh thank you
very much Eric yeah we scratched some
surface maybe we could continue possibly
but this is uh we're going to continue
with myth I just don't know which one
but this has been uh pill pod
137 for all the rest of our stuff it's
on uh
patreon.com excellent catch you next
time all right see you
see why did I say that see
ya sit up bye that was a that was a
[Music]
sign